over the past decade perky progressive
insurance saleswoman flow has become a
television mainstay appearing in dozens
of commercials but while everyone knows
Flo chances are you've never even heard
of Stephanie Courtney the woman who
plays the character let's change that
with a look at some things you didn't
know about the woman behind Flo Mommy
Dearest in a 2016 interview with lo HUD
Courtney gave the inside scoop on how
she landed the once in a lifetime role
the flow turns out she had a secret
weapon when she went to the audition her
mom Jane Courtney what they were looking
for was basically a friendly
neighborhood waitress she is super
friendly and nice almost to the point of
madness and I was like I can do that I
went straight to my mom and I credit her
with Flo's personality
I said yes I can become Jane Courtney
improv in her original audition Courtney
had just one line but during her second
audition the director invited her to
play with the role as a member of the
famous Groundlings improv comedy group
that was all the opening Courtney needed
progressive chief marketing officer Jeff
Kearney told Advertising Age that Flo
was an accident the character was just
supposed to be a friendly cashier in the
superstore but Courtney brought the
character to life when she ad-lib the
line Wow I say it louder
Wow no I say it louder have a great day
company execs realize the concept gave
them the chance to surround Flo with
characters to play off and offered other
opportunities to expand Flo's story
since that fateful audition Courtney has
continued to be an integral voice on how
the character of progressive Flo has
progressed and all thanks to one little
wow it just shows what can happen if you
say the right word slovakia triceratops
tapioca raquetball staccato glioma hi
mate pumpernickel pudding
she helps write the commercials in 2009
Courtney told cleveland.com about the
backstory she envisioned for plum saying
when I picture Flo in life she drives
her little Mini Cooper around town and
it's basically like when Bob Hoskins
drove into toontown and Who Framed Roger
Rabbit basically all the buildings and
the birds are singing in her mind
Courtney explained Aloha that over the
years she's worked with writers to shape
the arc of her character the writers are
very open to what I think there may be
some improv here
now and then that is encouraged by the
way all of us were working so hard to
find out who this person was and what
the boundaries were with flow she was
sort of originally this perfect little
number-one employee but the power has
gotten to it uh-oh sounds like her
little sidekick dude Jamie might want to
sleep with one eye open Jamie don't
forget to clean the fridge when you're
done she seems nice
she seems nice she's actually pretty
nice
she lived in France when Courtney was
just a child her family spent a year in
France though she later forgot how to
speak the language the experience came
in handy during her college years when
she spent a semester abroad with a host
family in Avignon still she told The
Nerdist JV club podcast that the culture
shock of returning to France was
difficult I ate like Olympic amounts of
bread and cheese and then I outgrew all
of my clothes and I remember I was so
sad like I really looked like Gerard
Depardieu I couldn't afford a haircut
like no makeup and I'd mope around
France because I felt so bad about
myself she's a playwright before landing
the life changing role of Flo Courtney
pan to play called those Courtney girls
based on exaggerated versions of herself
and her sister Jennifer and their lives
as broke actors those courtney girls ran
at the 2000 Aspen Comedy Festival the
Courtney says it didn't make a big
splash it did help her make more
contacts in the comedy business
networking that is clearly paid off way
to go Flo thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to